le cinéma avec la sortie mercredi
prochain de l'autre dumas un film où
l'on découvre qu'alexandre dumas ne
s'est pas contenté de sa seule plume
pour écrire ses chefs-d'oeuvre à ses
côtés il y avait auguste maquet un
érudit fouilleurs d'archivés qui
participa au succès du romancier 100 ans
cueillir les foyers voici sept histoires
interprétées par un duo d'acteurs gérard
depardieu et benoît poelvoorde le film
vu par marie-jo jouant et tristan le
brazza s'il très beau tu es un très
chaud là vivait dans l'ombre de l'autre
vous voulez on suit vous l'aurez donc
deux heures gérard depardieu est
alexandre dumas au plus près du reste un
con des moyens supplémentaires et au fil
des dialogues benoît poelvoorde auguste
maquet son [ __ ] littéraire onze ans
durant
alexandre dumas et auguste maquet ont
écrit ensemble les trois mousquetaires
le comte de monte cristo la reine margot
là est un génie l'autre pas mais ils ne
peuvent se passer l'un de l'autre c'est
magnifique à dix ans
sans auguste de bach et dumas n'aurait
pas pu être aussi libre échange c'est
vraiment l'histoire d'une amitié avant
tout une amitié mise en péril à cause
d'un quiproquo sublime à qui voulait
bien écrire une petite dédicace je vais
votre prénom
charlotte pour les beaux yeux d'une
jeune révolutionnaire mac et se fait
passer pour dumas
vous n'êtes pas ses nuits délicieuse la
fiction se mêle à l'histoire révélant
hauteur entièrement mû par ses pulsions
des personnages qui mangent la vie et
qui est extrêmement séduisant à qui on
ne peut pas en vouloir même s'il est
horrible c'est un personnage odieux et
il ya toujours des côtés des armes en
bloc
comment ce double caméra et commença par
exemple quand ces blocs bloc mais a dit
manquait plus que ça il a à côté de
clown triste c'est à dire qu'il est
beaucoup plus effacé ce qui sera son
chagrin et sa difficulté j'en ai c'est
de voir à côté de d'alexandre dumas qui
est si fort si quintet empannage temps
le bagout un homme qui lui écrit tout
autant mais qui n'arrivent pas à exclure
et aussi bien son avis il faut
s'attaquer le studio mac et n'aura de
cesse de revendiquer son rôle de co
auteur sans jamais obtenir gain de cause
que celle d'être en guerre contre moi je
dirais aux journalistes que je suis à la
source de tous bords l'ogre devant son
miroir c'est ce que fut sans doute dumas
face à macaye d'user quoi c'est clair la
reine margot alexandre dumas depardieu
face à paul board c'est simplement un
grand duo d'acteurs